what is a two-way Anova a two-way Anova
is a statistical method used to test the
effect of two categorical variables on a
continuous variable the categorical
variables are the independent variables
for example the variable drag type with
drug A and B and gender with female and
male and the continuous variable is the
dependent variable for example the
reduction in blood pressure so the
two-way Anova is the extension of the
one-way Anova while a oneway Anova tests
the effect of a single independent
variable on a dependent variable a
two-way Anova tests the effects of two
independent variables the independent
variables are called factors but what is
a factor a factor is for example gender
of a person with the levels May male and
female type of therapy with therapy a b
and c or the field of study with
medicine business administration
psychology and Mathematics in an
analysis of variance a factor is
therefore a nominal variable we use an
anova whenever we want to test whether
these levels have an influence on the
so-called dependent variable you might
want to test whether genda has an effect
on salary whether therapy has an effect
on blood pressure or whether field of
study has an effect on length of study
celery blood pressure and length of
study will then be the dependent
variables in each of these cases you
test whether the factor has an effect on
the dependent variable since you only
have one factor in these cases you would
use a oneway Anova okay you're right in
the first case we have a variable with
only two categories so of course we
would use the independent samples T Test
but when do we use a two-way Anova we
use a two factor analysis of variance
when we have a second factor and we want
to know whether this Factor also has an
effect on the dependent variable we
would also like to know whether in
addition to gender the highest level of
education has an impact on salary or we
would like to include gender in addition
to type of therapy or in the third case
we would also like to know whether the
university attended in addition to the
field of study has an influence on the
length of study now we don't have one
factor in all three cases but two
factors in each case and since we now
have two factors we use a two-way
analysis of variant so in a oneway andov
we have one factor from which we create
the groups if the factor we're looking
at has three levels for example three
different types of drug we will have
three groups to compare in the case of a
two-way analysis of variance the group
results from the combination of the
levels of the two factors if we have one
factor with three levels and one with
two levels
we have a total of six groups to compare
but what kind of statements can we make
with a two-way Anova with the help of a
two-way Anova we can answer three things
whether the first Factor has an effect
on the dependent variable whether the
second Factor has an effect on the
dependent variable and whether there is
an interaction effect between the two
factors but what about the hypotheses in
a two-way and the over there are three
null hypotheses and therefore also three
alternative hypotheses the first null
hypothesis is there is no significant
difference between the groups of the
first factor and the alternative
hypothesis there is a significant
difference between the groups of the
first Factor the second Nile hypothesis
is there is no significant difference
between the groups of the second factor
and the alternative hypothesis there is
a significant difference between the
groups of the second factor and the
third null hypothesis reflects the
interaction Effect one factor has no
effect on the effect of the other factor
and the alternative hypothesis at least
one factor has an influence on the
effect of the other factor and what
about the assumptions for the test
results to be valid several assumptions
must be met now number one normality the
data within the groups should be
normally distributed or alternatively
the residual should be normally
distributed this can be checked with a
quantile quantile plot Number Two
homogeneity of variances the variance of
data in groups should be equal this can
be checked with the Lin test number
three Independence the measurements
should be independent I.E the measured
value of one group should not be
influenced by the measured value of
another group number four measurement
level the dependent variable should have
a metrix scale level but how to
calculate a two-way Anova let's look at
the example from the beginning we would
like to know if drag type and gender
have an influence on the reduction in
blood pressure drag type has the two
levels drag A and B and gender has the
two levels male and female to answer the
question we collect data we randomly
assigned patients to the treatment
combinations and measured the reduction
in blood pressure after a month for
example the first patient reive Dr a is
male and after one month a reduction in
blood pressure of six was measured now
let us answer the questions is there a
main effect of drag type on the
reduction in blood pressure is there a
main effect of gender on the reduction
in blood pressure and is there an
interaction effect between drag type and
gender on the reduction in blood
pressure for the calculation we can use
either a statistical software like data
tyab or do it by hand first I will show
you how to calculate it with data Tab
and how to interpret the results at the
end I will show you how to calculate the
Anova by hand and go through all the
equations
to calculate a two-way Anova online
simply visit data.net and copy your data
into this table then click on hypothesis
test under this tab you will find a lot
of hypothesis tests and depending on
which variable you select you will get
an appropriate hypothesis test suggested
we want to know if drag type and gender
have an influence on the reduction in
blood pressure so let's just click on
all three variables data now
automatically gives us a two-way andov
we can read the three null and the three
alternative hypotheses here afterwards
we get the descriptive statistics and
the leine test for equal variance with
the LaVine test we can check if the
variances within the groups are equal
the P value is greater than
0.05 so we assume equality of VAR in a
groups for this data and here we see the
results of the analysis of variance
we'll look at these in more detail in a
moment but if you don't know exactly how
to interpret the results you can also
just click on summary in
words in addition you can check here if
the requirements for the analysis of
variance are met at all but now back to
the results let's take a closer look at
this table the first row tests the null
hypothesis whether drag type has an
effect on the reduction in blood
pressure the second row tests whether
gender has an effect on the reduction in
blood pressure and the third row tests
if the interaction has an effect you can
read the P value in each case right at
the back here let's say we set the
significance level at 5% if our
calculated P value is less than 0.0 0 5
the null hypothesis is rejected and if
the calculated P value is greater than
0.05 the null hypothesis is not rejected
thus we see that all three p values are
greater than
0.05 and therefore we cannot reject any
of the three null hypotheses therefore
neither the drug type nor gender have a
significant effect on the reduction in
blood pressure and there's also no no
significant interaction effect but what
does an analysis of variance actually do
and why is the word variance in analysis
of variance in a two-way analysis of
variance the total variance of the
dependent variable is divided into the
variance that can be explained by factor
a the variance that can be explained by
Factor B the variance of the interaction
and the error variance actually SS is
not the variance but the sum of squares
we will discuss how to calculate the
variance in this case in a moment but
how can I imagine that the dependent
variable has some variance in our
example not everyone will have the same
reduction in blood pressure we now want
to know if we can explain sum of this
variance by the variable stru type
gender and their interaction
the part that we cannot explain by these
three terms accumulates in the error if
the result looked like this we would be
able to explain almost all the variance
by factors A and B and their interaction
and we would only have a very small
proportion that could not be explained
this means that we can make a very good
statement about the reduction in blood
pressure by the variable drug type sex
and interaction
in this case it would be the other way
around drag type gender and the
interaction almost have no effect on the
reduction in blood pressure and it all
adds up in the arrow but how do we
calculate the sum of squares the F value
and the P value here we have our data
one's drug type with drug A and B and
one's gender with male and female so
these individuals are for example all
male and have been given given drug a
first we calculate the mean values we
need we calculate the mean value of each
group so male and drag a that is 5.8
then male and Drug B that is 5.4 and we
do the same for female then we calculate
the mean value of all males and females
and the mean value of drug A and B
finally we need the total mean we can
now now start to calculate the sum of
squares let's start with the total sum
of squares we do this by subtracting the
total mean from each individual value
squaring the result and adding up all
the values the total mean is 5.4 so we
calculate 6 - 5.4 2ar + 4 - 5.4 squared
to finally 3 - 5.4 squar so we get a sum
of squares of
84.8 the degrees of freedom are given by
n * P * Q - 1 n is the number of people
in a group in our case five and P and Q
are the number of categories in each of
the factors in both cases we have two
groups the total variance is calculated
by dividing the sum of squares by the
degrees of freedom them so we get
4.46 now we can calculate the sum of
squares between the groups for this we
calculate the group mean minus the total
mean so 5.8 minus 5.4 squared + 5.4 -
5.4 squared and the same for these two
values we get
7.6 in this case the degrees of freedom
are three which gives us a variance of
2.53 now we can calculate the sum of
squares of factor a a dash is the mean
value of the categories of factor a so
we calculate
5.9 minus the total mean value and 4.9
minus the total mean value this results
in five together with the degrees of
freedom we can now calculate the
variance for factor a which is five we
do the same for Factor B in this case we
use the mean values of male and female
and we get the variance of
0.8 now we can calculate the sum of
squares for the interaction we obtain
this by calculating the sum of squares
minus the sum of squares of A and B the
degrees of freedom result to one for the
interaction we get a variance of
1.8 finally we can calculate the sum of
squares of the error we substract the
mean value of each group from the
respective group values so in this group
we subtract 5.8 from each individual
value in this group we substract
5.4 here we substract six and then we
substract 4.4 this gives us a sum of
squares of
77.2 the degrees of freedom are 16 and
we get a variance of
4.83 and now we calculate the F values
these are obtained by dividing the
variance of factor a b or the
interaction by the arrow variance so we
get the F value for factor a by dividing
the variance of factor a by the aror
variance which is equal to
1.04 we can now do exactly the same for
FB and faab to verify we get exactly the
same values with data tab
1.04
0.17 and
0.37 for the calculation of the P value
you need the degrees of freedom and the
F distribution so with these three
values you can either read a critical P
value in a table or as usual you just
use a software to calculate the P values
you can find a table of critical F
values on data tab EG for a significance
level of 5% you can use this table if
the red value is greater than the
calculated F value the Nal hypothesis is
rejected otherwise not I hope you
enjoyed the video and see you next
time